عندما يؤكد بايدن تلقيه موافقه من نتنياهو
على موضوع حل الدولتين ثم يؤكد نتنياهو
رفضه لاقامه دوله فلسطينيه مباشره بعد
تصريح بايدن ما السيناريوهات في تقديرك
التي دفعت بايدن لان يصرح
بذلك نعم تحيه لك محمد ولضيفك وللمشاهدة
امام حزبه خاصه ال الج القطاع الشعب من
حزبه الذي يريد وقفا فوريا لهذه المجزره
ضد الفلسطينيين وقفا لاطلاق ان يكون هناك
وقف لاطلاق النار على الفور يطالبوا بان
ينال الفلسطينيون حقهم في تقرير مصيرهم
يطالبون بدوله فلسطينيه فهو باستمرار
يحاول ان يخاطب هذا القطاع وهو قطاع مهم
جدا له في الانتخابات المقبله بدون لن
يتمكن ان يفوز بدوره ثانيه ولكن ما يقوله
نتنيا حقيقه هو منسجم تماما مع ما قاله
نتنياهو تاريخيا تاريخيا نتنياهو يعتز انه
يعارض فكره الدوله الفلسطينيه تاريخيا
يقول انا الذي ابطلت هذه العمليه يقول انه
هو حتى كان مقتنع ان رابين لم يكن يريد
دوله فلسطينيه فليس هناك جديدا فيما يقوله
نتنياهو انا في تقديري ان هناك ربما خلاف
في قراءه المشهد من قبل الاداره الامريكيه
التي في نهايه المطاف هي صاحبه القرار
بشان الحرب او بشان السلم اذا كانت تريد
ان يكون هناك وقفا لاطلاق النار ستفعله
على الفور اذا كانت تريد ان يكون هناك
دوله فلسطينيه لكان هناك دوله فلسطينيه
الواقع هو اخي محمد ان هذه ان الادارات
الامريكيه المتتابعه منذ عام 93 و حتى
اليوم منذ اتفاق اصو لم تفعل شيء لتفعيل
فكره الدوله الفلسطينيه كان من المفترض ان
تقوم هذه الدوله عام 98 ولم تقوم الولايات
المتحده لم تفعل شيئا اذاء استشراء
الاستيطان مضاعفته وتضاعف عدد المستوطنين
فاذا هي حقيقه التزامها بالدوله
الفلسطينيه هو التزام شفوي لا اكثر